friends
we are at a critical moment for our
country
we face huge challenges in the aftermath
of covid and putin's appalling war
in ukraine
now is the time to be bold
we cannot have business as usual
economic management
which has led to low growth for decades
we need to deliver on brexit and the
opportunities it offers
and we need to win the fight for freedom
at home and around the world
that is why i am putting myself forward
for leadership of the conservative and
unionist party and our great country
i will campaign as a conservative and i
will govern as a conservative
i can lead i can make tough decisions
and i can get things done
i am ready to be prime minister from day
one
i got to where i am today through hard
work and aspiration
i didn't come from a traditional
conservative background
i grew up in paisley and i went to
comprehensive school in leeds
many of the children i were at school
with were let down by low expectations
poor educational standards and a lack of
opportunity
too much talent went to waste
i didn't believe and i don't believe
that it has to be that way
and that's why i went into politics
i care deeply about our country
i want us to be an aspiration nation
where people from all backgrounds and
all parts of the united kingdom have the
opportunity to have a great education
be able to start their own businesses
and realize their dreams
everyone should have the same
opportunity regardless of their
background or way they live
and that is what leveling up is in a
conservative way
i have a plan to make britain a high
growth economy over the next 10 years
through bold supply side
reform we will cut taxes helping
businesses invest in their future
will tackle the cost of energy and will
control government spending
we will create new low tax low
regulation zones to attract investment
in communities up and down our country
creating new hubs for innovation and
enterprise
we can revitalize local areas in the
same way as we regenerated the london
docklands
families are a vital part of our lives
and a crucial building block for a
stable society
they don't just look after themselves
but they're part of communities
charities and even businesses
we will review the taxation of families
to ensure that people aren't penalized
for taking time out to care for children
or elderly relatives
will turbo charge the rural economy
by focusing on farmers growing food
and cutting the pointless regulation
that gets in their way
we need to be honest with the public
this will be tough
it will take time
but i am determined to deliver
[Applause]
i know i can deliver
because i have taken bold decisions and
made bold reforms throughout my career
after working in the energy and telecoms
industry i set up the free enterprise
group in parliament
i made the case with like-minded
colleagues for an open competitive
dynamic economy
in government
i've consistently delivered and i've
taken tough decisions
i stood up to vladimir putin by
targeting russia with the toughest
sanctions his regime has ever seen and i
would continue to lead the free world in
opposing putin and making sure that
ukraine prevails
i don't give in to whitehall
i don't give in to vested interests
and i don't give in to the naysayers
i've proved time and time again that i
can deliver even when it's difficult
as trade secretary i struck dozens of
trade deals with major partners such as
australia
and japan
when people told me that it simply
wouldn't be possible
in the face of eu intransigence i
developed the northern ireland protocol
bill
it breaks the dead walk in a legal way
upholding the belfast good friday
agreement and preventing the tearing
apart of our precious union
as chief secretary to the treasury
i had a firm grip on our nation's
finances
i am prepared to do whatever it takes to
get the job done
that
my friends
is why i am trusted to deliver
we have to level with the british public
that our economy will not get back on
track overnight
times are going to be tough
but i know that i can get us on an
upward trajectory by 2024
we can get there by delivering our
promises
ensuring spades are in the ground people
are in jobs and money is being generated
in local areas right across our country
i can know it can be delivered by
working relentlessly together as a team
of focusing on delivery delivery and
delivery
that's how we can turn things around and
that's how the conservatives can win the
next election
we don't have a moment to lose and i
will work with colleagues from right
across the party to lead a strong and
united team
let me be clear
labor is beatable the liberals are
beatable
there isn't a great groundswell of
support in the country
for sicker stammer or sarah davey
what the british people are crying out
for is a modern and united conservative
party
ready with the courage of its
convictions to deliver on the promises
that we have made
so my friends
you can trust me
to get the economy going
to get money back in people's pockets
and to help squeeze families
together we will level up the country in
a conservative way
making it an aspiration
nation
together we will continue to defy the
voices of decline
and stand tall
on the world stage
so let's get on and deliver for our
great country like never before thank
you
so
i start with beth rigby of sky thank you
um
liz trust you've just said that the
country wants a modern and united
conservative party but the two
candidates ahead of you
in this race have one thing in common
they're a break from boris johnson
rishi sonak resigned from his government
you did not and penny morden was never
in his cabinet or only for a brief
moment
and they've leaped frog u in the race
given the bitter divisions of recent
months is boris johnson's tax tacit
backing of you the kiss of death for
your candidacy given that the party
wants change even if you did not thank
you
the change we need to deliver
is change on the economy
we've had sluggish growth for two
decades and we need a new economic plan
and i'm somebody who can work with the
team from right across the conservative
party to deliver on transforming our
economy
cutting taxes for ordinary people across
the country
getting investment into all areas from
the north to the south scotland northern
ireland and wales
helping us
deliver the next general election
but most importantly helping us to live
a brighter brighter future for
johnson's britain when so many
colleagues did
i'm a loyal person i'm loyal to boris
johnson i supported
our prime minister's aspirations and i
want to deliver the promise of the 2019
manifesto
and what we need to do now is deliver
deliver deliver and i am the person in
this race with the record of delivery
i've taken the tough decisions at the
foreign office at the trade department
i've got a fantastic team of people in
my campaign team and more broadly across
the party and i want to go in from day
one in downing street and make sure we
deliver on the promises we set out in
2019.
great
uh chris mason chris mason from bbc news
how can you be the credible agent of
change given you have sat around boris
johnson's cabinet table throughout his
time as prime minister and and if i may
um how would are you that your campaign
is being trampled by the march of
mordant
well
as you know i've been focusing on
making sure that vladimir putin is
defeated in ukraine and we led that
effort we led the fight for the free
world we put on more sanctions than any
other country
we have encouraged others to stand tough
we were the first country to send
weapons to ukraine and i'm proud of that
record now internally within government
i was critical within cabinet of the
proposed national insurance rise i was a
cabinet minister who spoke out against
it at the time but i'm a loyalist i
believe in collective responsibility but
now we are now the prime minister has
stood down i think it's right that i'm
honest about my views on the economy i
spent two years as chief secretary i can
deliver a different economic plan that
is credible and will work for the people
of britain and deliver on the promises
that we made in the 2019 manifesto
thank you anusha
thank you
itv news elizabeth you voted remain and
you remained in the cabinet when tax
rises came in
penny morden
backed brexit from the start some say
she's the real candidate of the right
given that analysts say she is going to
beat you
wouldn't the right thing be for party
unity to swing behind her
well since the referendum in 2016
i have done
so much to deliver on the promises of
brexit and the opportunities of brexit
i've delivered dozens of trade deals at
the department of trade i've delivered
the northern ireland protocol bill to
fix the issues that we have in northern
ireland and as prime minister
i am committed to unleashing the full
opportunities of brexit the ability to
do things differently whether that's in
financial services whether it's in
regulation to really get our economy
going and i'm the candidate in this race
that has the record of delivery i've
shown that i'm prepared to get difficult
stuff done in whitehall i'm ready to hit
the ground running from day one we've
only got two years till the general
election
and my experience my record of delivery
is needed to get the job done
uh
jack jack allison
thank you secretary you said just now
you wanted to be honest about your plan
for the economy uh the government in
which you serve currently has a tax plan
to cut the basic rate of income tax by
1p by 2024 um that's not enough is it
and what would you like to see income
tax cut to
well on day one
we would start by having a new budget
and a new spending review it's vitally
important that we reverse the national
insurance rises
that we don't increase corporation tax
because we need to get investment into
all parts of our country i also want to
put in place low tax zones particularly
in areas like the north of england to
help attract enterprise i think that's
vitally important
and the way i see the cover debt
is it's a one-off event it's a one in a
hundred year event we should pay that
debt off over a longer period of time
that is how i would fund my tax
reductions whilst at the same time
laying out a clear plan a clear 10-year
plan to reform
the government and the public sector and
to do all those supply-side reforms i've
talked about to really get the economy
motoring because we have had anemic
growth for the past two decades
and more of the same simply isn't going
to work to deliver for the people of
britain
uh jason jason groves
[Applause]
thank you um you've worked uh with penny
mordent in government you've done some
of the same uh jobs as her with
equalities at trade on
brexit
your friend lord foss this morning said
she's not up to the job do you agree
with them
well actually i i haven't worked in the
same department as penny mordent and i
certainly won't be making any
disparaging comments about any of my
fellow candidates i think in fact the
conservative race shows what a broad
range of talent we have in the
conservative party and we didn't get
there through identity politics we
didn't get there through quotas we got
there because we are a meritocratic
party that believes in the future of
britain yeah
uh ben reilly smith
thank you two quick uh policy questions
defense spending what percentage of gdp
would you want to see spent on defense
and would you keep boris johnson's randa
deportation policy
i want to see
by the end of the decade
defense spending going up to three
percent of gdp i think it's vitally
important
with increased insecurity in europe and
across the world that we are putting our
money where our mouth is the fact is the
free world didn't spend enough on
defense
and we saw the results in terms of the
appalling russian aggression in ukraine
if we don't make sure that russia is
defeated in ukraine we could see even
worse taking place across europe so it
is vitally important that we reform
government
so we can afford to spend more on
defense and part of that is helping more
people get into work
reforming our
our welfare
system to make sure that we are
encouraging that having proper
incentives for people to go into work
this is why the national insurance rise
is so wrong uh because we need to make
sure that people are encouraged to take
up those opportunities
i completely agree with the rwanda
policy i've worked very closely with
pretty patel on it
and we need to
have further reforms
in the united kingdom to make sure that
we can really stop illegal immigration
steve swinford
um foreign secretary you talk about
running a positive campaign and not
criticizing your rivals but many of the
people sitting in front of you in your
own team have been publicly very
critical of your rivals they've said
that rishi sunak has been plotting to
undermine the prime minister for six
months they've publicly accused rishi
sunak of orchestrating a dirty tricks
campaign through gavin williamson this
morning people around your team are
saying that penny morgan would need
stabilizers if she became prime minister
do you endorse these very personal
attacks on your rivals or would you like
the people in front of you not to not to
carry them out anymore
as you've heard today steve i'm putting
forward a positive agenda
i want to transform our country i think
the most pressing issue is the economy
we need to hit the ground running from
day one i'm the prime minister that can
do that and i want to have a team from
across the conservative party getting
all of our talents on the pitch to be
able to do that thank you thank you
everybody for the questions very good
[Applause]
well liz trust launching her campaign
this morning welcome to central lobby
here in the palace of westminster we're
right in the middle of the building to
one side we have the house of commons to
the other the house of lords right in
the middle is tamara with me what did we
make of what she had to say good morning
kay well an assured speech by the
foreign secretary she could walk in to
downing street on day one she um she
doesn't need
any training for it she's been in
cabinet for seven years and she wants
lower taxes than we have at the moment
and she says that she can stand up to
vladimir putin and russian aggression so
she's trying to be the candidate of
experience a lot of the questions um
from journalists at that launch focused
on the fact that there's no getting away
from the fact that she did not get as
good a result as she would have wanted
yesterday in the first ballot of mps
which she soon as expected was in the
lead but penny moored surging behind him
the momentum seems to be with her and
then we've got that
polling yesterday from conservative
party members showing that she's also
the runaway favorite with them so can is
trust beat mordant can she unite the
right of the conservative party behind
her well at the moment she has to show
that in this second ballot today and if
we see a couple of the lesser-known
candidates people like suella bravaman
for example is probably the most
right-wing candidate in the contest
dropping out and their support going to
trust then she could
start to recoup lost ground but she
really needs to get some momentum going
now i thought to detect a slight
touchiness in some of her answers about
penny mordent although she insisted she
wasn't going to make disparaging
comments plenty of her supporters have
done not privately but publicly and
suggested that penny morden does not
have the experience to go and run number
10. she didn't answer head-on though
that question did she when she was asked
about it no she said that she wouldn't
be making disparaging comments and that
she'd not worked with penny morgan in
government she um penny morgan was
defense secretary for about three months
during the latter days of theresa may
when liz trust was also in the cabinet
so they must have worked together a bit
but she didn't
give away anything about that but
certainly you look at people like simon
clark cabinet minister at the treasury
he has said this morning that
conservatives and the country need to be
concerned about the prospect of somebody
who has not got the right experience
going into number 10. it was interesting
that she talked about president putin
because when i asked her
she told me that she'd never met
president putin but i suppose that's a
question for another day when the
debates take place talk to us before we
move on talk to us about the geography
of where we are we're in something
called central lobby so for the benefit
of our viewers where are we what happens
here why is this a good place for us to
be today this is the historic central
lobby this is where you will see
people coming in to meet their mps
you'll see mps
coming together to talk to plot a bit
you often see mps sitting on these
benches around me having meetings and
this is the sort of beating heart of
parliament before we had um port cullis
house which is the new glass bit of
parliament where we often go now this
was where mps would meet you've got the
house of lords coming off one end the
house of commons off another and this is
where mps would would come in um our
before and after votes and to before
going into one of the two the two
chambers and this is where any member of
the public can come they need to be
invited but anyone can come here yes
anyone can come here they can't of
course go into the chambers but they can
they can arrange to meet their mps here
and and they can um when they when they
come in mps will typically meet them
here and this is where mps meet after
votes and this is where also the warren
of committee rooms where you get to some
of those so when we hear about committee
room 14 that's that yes
so there's a corridor of committee rooms
and in one of them today there will be
the 1922 committee
at three o'clock announcing the results
of the second ballot so all of these
committee rooms are busy all day long
with different hearings but it's in
these sort of
hot committee rooms that the tory
leadership stages in parliament will be
decided before the final two go to the
membership it's an absolutely stunning
building look at that chandelier
absolutely gorgeous they do do tours
here all the time so a lot of young
people they're trying to get involved in
politics and show them that it's not dry
and it's not boring and we're certainly
seeing that with this uh leadership
contest indeed i mean
labour are saying this is a circus and
this does not reflect well on the
country to have all this fighting
among the governing party but certainly
some conservatives while hoping it's
over quickly say it shows that there's a
genuine battle of ideas there um for for
the soul of the party you've got
candidates who
members of the public will have barely
heard of doing pretty well in this
contest tell us about more established
figures you know jeremy hunt former
foreign secretary out yesterday nadim
zahawi in cabinet for a while now the
chancellor out of the contest and yet
you see people like kemi badanok a local
government uh minister who um who came
from nigeria as a child she and you know
worked in banking for going into
politics she's got 40 votes from her
colleagues to be the next prime minister
suella bravaman who is on the very
right-wing brexiteer end of the
conservative party is talking about
leaving the european convention on human
rights she got quite a lot of support
from
from the erg there the group of mps who
made life very difficult for theresa may
with her brexit deal she's done very
well as well i mean this is really the
next generation of conservatives uh who
we're starting to see come through here
and even if they do early for them yeah
it feels like it is too early my sister
may be in line to go out
this in this vote because she got the
fewest of those remaining in the contest
she got the fewest votes yesterday and
it's hard to see where she picks them up
given that liz trust is very much trying
to appeal to conservatives on the right
so if she goes out then trust will hope
to pick up many of her votes kenny
vadernock as well if she were to go out
today don't forget if more than one mp
is in the last place so if you're tied
in last place you both go out so
she may also
be at risk today but um she has picked
up support not on the not on the right
more on the sort of culture war
side of the of the party people who um
say that that um some things that are
happening politics are too woke she's
very concerned about regulation of the
online world so she's attracted a lot of
support which will need to be picked up
elsewhere as well but you can imagine
that both of them may well be in line
for a job in someone's cabinet
politics is brutal though isn't it i
mean i was speaking to the camps of um
jeremy hunt and also
excuse me sir how we yesterday last
night once they were out and they were
writing hi both those guys and what
happened
it really is brutal i mean those who
think that they are going to do well on
sometimes end up not doing well and i
think if jeremy hunt in particular the
number of declared supporters was more
than the number who actually voted for
him so obviously a couple of people had
told him four keepers you're my guy and
then it and then that didn't happen and
indeed you know jeremy hunt declared for
rishi cenac late last night said he was
supporting him that would have been a
massive disappointment to penny mordant
who supported him for the leadership in
2019 he supported his act as defence
secretary you know obviously the job of
a lifetime and for supporting him when
boris johnson got in and reached revenge
on the people who didn't back him so she
would have been disappointed tom tugan
had who and the former soldier also um
had pretty good contest for someone
who's never held a ministerial job he
sees himself as the one nation sort of
um one nation candidate of the tory
party he would have wanted jeremy hunt's
support as well so you know it is brutal
you don't know who your friends are
until it really comes to the crunch and
we are seeing now that some of the
lesser-known candidates who members of
the public probably wouldn't even
recognize the bus stop are now
really getting to the final stages in
the race to be the next prime minister
and the vote is at 11 30 opens at 11 30
360 mps conversion there were 357 voting
yesterday right you've sort of lost the
whip or
but yeah 357 voting rishi sunac picked
up the support of about a quarter of
them yesterday and he needs 119
well he'll be hoping to take a
a commanding lead um but he's been 29. i
can't remember 129 he needs yeah i spoke
to a very senior memphis team yesterday
who in the morning who said to me we're
not going to get 100 votes i wondered if
it was expectation management but
said boris johnson got well over 100 in
the first ballot three years ago they
said he can't because of the way the
thresholds are working and the way
people want to keep certain candidates
in the contest and that means they have
to get at least 30. he they said he
couldn't get 100. that's in the end what
happened but i think yesterday looking
at those numbers you see that liz trust
the foreign secretary who supported
boris johnson to the very end some say
she's just going to be continuity boris
johnson she only got 50 and she will
need to find some momentum somewhere um
we'll know about three o'clock won't we
is there a lower threshold this time
thresholds this time lowest candidate
goes if there's more than one candidate
tied and they both go and of course
anyone can at any point decide to drop
out of the race so so just to clarify
one will go if somebody gets one they're
out but if somebody gets two votes they
can stay in yes unlike what happened
yesterday that's right i mean i don't
think that's likely because most of the
candidates hope to retain their support
they've already got but yes um i think
you say that but it's interesting that
we were hearing from um therese coffee
who was representing liz trust this
morning
basically saying to uh the people who
are representing
um
yeah uh
yeah saying join us come and join us yes
and will they do that today i mean we'll
see jeremy hunting the deems of harwi's
supporters that's 18 and 25 respectively
um going going to other camps so where
do those 43 votes go i mean some of them
will probably join jeremy hunt in the
rishi sunac camp but others may support
other candidates don't think either
their supporters will probably go to
suella braverman which makes me think
she may be the first to exit the race
today but certainly if we see kemi
badanok picking up any more support
people deciding that regardless of the
fact that she's unlikely to win the
whole thing they still want to keep her
in the contest then that could things
could start to get very unpredictable
um interesting that we should maybe just
develop a little bit further on what we
were saying about jeremy humps not
supporting penny mordant and why that
seemed to be particularly brutal because
she actually lost her job didn't she for
supporting him yes do you remember the
2019 leadership contest boris johnson
versus jeremy hunt in the final two they
went on hostings around the country and
penny mordant who was had been made
defence secretary only in the may and
this was the contest um ended with boris
johnson becoming prime minister in july
she supported jeremy hunt she went out
on a limb others um other senior figures
in the party members of the cabinet
swallowed some doubts i would say and uh
supported boris johnson some of the
young thrusters in the party like rishi
sunak robert generic oliver dowd and
they all said we must have boris johnson
to deliver brexit
and although penny morden actually lent
him a lot of credibility because she had
been a brexiteer and said i believe
jeremy hunt can do this
he he didn't win boris johnson wreaked
his revenge on everybody who didn't
support him he had
quite a substantial cabinet reshuffle at
the beginning when he came in penny
morgan was out she later made us sort of
come back as a trade minister but never
back in the cabinet under boris johnson
so she made sacrifices for jeremy hunt
he did not return the favor yesterday
but also tom tugan hat supporters are
also raging about uh jeremy hunt not not
supporting not supporting him and they
say giving the the one nation uh wing of
the party more of a chance i wonder why
he wanted rishi sunak as
falling behind him should we talk about
that after the break
why don't we